well welcome to everybody who's joined
us this afternoon for what's already
been a great day I have to say and I'm
expecting wonderful wonderful next two
hours with our guest speaker I'm really
delighted to introduce dr. Nadia Al Ahly
who's a professor of Gender Studies in
the Center for gender studies at the
School of Oriental and African Studies
so as University of London professor
Ali's main research interests involved
gender theory feminist activism women
and gender in the Middle East
transnational my egg migration and
diaspora mobilization war conflict and
reconstruction and she's done
anthropological research on these topics
in a variety of places including Egypt
Iraq Jordan as well as the United
Kingdom and the United States
professor Anna Lee is the author of many
path-breaking books several of which I
have to say I've used with great success
in my graduate course on culture and
politics and the contemporary Middle
East I would say her the two books that
maybe she's best known for our Iraqi
women untold stories from 1948 to the
present and what kind of liberation
women and the occupation of Iraq but she
has a number of other volumes and
collections including women and war in
the Middle East
transnational perspectives new
approaches to migration secularism
gender in the state in the Middle East
and gender writing writing gender her
most recent book which is co-edited with
Deborah al-najjar is entitled we are
Iraqis aesthetics and politics in a time
of war professor al aliy was president
of JM uses parent organization the
Association of Middle East Women's
Studies or a Muse from night from 2009
to 2011 and I have to say Nadia I think
you were one of the very best Amyas
presidents ever she was an activist
president which is what we want
and you know since that time she's been
very actively involved with our journal
Jay Mewes and she's an associate editor
of Jamie since 2009 recently she's been
elected to the board of directors of the
Middle East Studies Association or Mesa
and under more activist sort of her
activist credential she's a member of
the feminist review collective and a
founding member of act together women's
Action for anak currently she's
facilitating the introduction of women's
and gender studies into Iraqi higher
education while working with Iraqi
women's rights activists in increasing
the capacity for evidence-based research
in that country and I have to say
literally I got this on email yesterday
as I said in my introduction this
morning I'm Amy started out not with our
journal J news but with a a hardcopy
bulletin of member news and we decided
and it kind of got lost a little bit
over the years but in this past year
under the presidency of Houghton asada
we've started up an a journal I'm a
bulletin is called a musi bulletin and
Nadia just wrote a brilliant overview
that I read this morning and I highly
recommend it it's in the April 2013
issue of a Muse a Bolton called ten
years after the invasion what happened
to Iraqi women I'm very compelling
analysis about some losses a few gains
but mostly how women's activism and
gender issues sort of got swept under
the carpet in the past decade and so
she's as you can see there's some
several thematic stir work but she's
really been one of the only really I
would say feminist writers Middle East
women's studies scholars really working
on a rock
you know we turn to her work in in that
regard but she's also interested in
these more general issues of gender and
activism across the the region and so we
are very delighted to introduce this
extraordinary scholar and activist it
will be speaking to us about gendering
rage protest cultural productions and
the making of new men and
in the Middle East so we welcome for
custom Nadia Alawi thank you very much
moisture I'm really happy to be here and
I would like to thank Jimmy is
particularly Marcia and of course also
very much bonny Rose for inviting me and
for organizing this excellent workshop
today and I would also like to take the
opportunity to take it to thank both
Marcia and Bonnie Rose for the amazing
work you have been doing for Jay Mewes
and I feel very happy and proud with the
quality of the journal which has really
gone from strength to strength and I'm
really honored to be here today
now when Marsha and Bonnie Rose asked me
about a theme for today's workshop I
strongly felt that activism should
feature prominently and what I had in
mind was not only activism respect to
the Middle East are speaking about
activism in the region but what I also
wanted to do was to actually create a
space in which we can talk about the
productive but also sometimes tense
relationship between scholarship
academia and activism no for me academia
and activism are actually inseparable
and combined in interesting and complex
ways researching on action being
simultaneously a researcher and activist
being an activist reflecting on action
now I'm not keen on reproducing a
dichotomy of theoretical versus
political as a doozie Theory politics
and praxis closely intertwined and
constitute constitutive of each other
however I think it would be this end
disingenuous to not mention that
activism and academia do each carry
their own set of rules requirements and
trials and that these are not always in
harmony with each other so I mean what
I'm thinking about here are for instance
you know research emphasis and focus the
methods of research what and where to
publish
in which context and how to engage with
the public particularly in terms of
language emphasis and tone and I should
say when I look at my PhD that was
published at the time when I read it now
I'm looking at it I'm thinking oh my god
this is so jargony but it was the kind
of rite of passage and I feel now I have
to say I feel much more free to not use
jargon and I think that having worked on
Iraq and Iraqi women I think it would
have been unethical if I just written to
the 2030 experts in the field I think it
was really important for me to try to
write to find a way to speak in a
language that is more accessible and
also to speak to different in different
contexts having said that I don't think
that it's mutually exclusive I think it
is important to theorize and I think
it's also important to maybe sort of
push boundaries a bit further but I
think for me this has been a dialectic
process now academic standards call for
great rigor if the research is not to
come across like mere partisans
storytelling at the same time as my
friend and colleague Cynthia's Coburn
has argued on numerous occasions
politically we need to be profoundly
responsible towards Co activists if we
aren't to exploit them in the interest
of our academic careers we also know
that it is not only academics but also
activists who can build useful knowledge
even theory and then again two out of
theory can come progressive change
interestingly and I'm I would like to
maybe have a discussion with you about
this I find that it is mainly in the
United States that people ask me how can
you combine academia activism it doesn't
happen so much in other contexts and so
I I would like to know from you maybe in
the discussion later on why you think
that is I should also say that I
originally meant to focus more
specifically
on evolutionary and counter illusionary
processes in the region as you notice
I'm not using the term Arab Spring and
I'm not only using not I'm not using it
not only because of the spring bit but
also because of the Arab bit you know I
think that it's really sort of glosses
over the diversity of ethnic groups and
the context I've been working actually
Kurds in the north of Iraq who have been
very much
maybe even more engaged in protest
movements and they obviously don't like
to be subsumed under the term Arab
Spring but I decided that given the
historical significance and developments
in Iraq I'm speaking here about the 10th
anniversary of the invasion and the
ongoing and acute political crisis and
lack of security and you know regular
bombings as well as increased
gender-based violence what I want to do
instead would instead but I'm sort of
slightly shifting here is to talk to you
about a series of issues that emerged
initially in the context of my work and
activism in andand Iraq but as I will
argue are also relevant when we look at
current developments in the region and
most particularly Egypt and particularly
sort of thinking about Egypt and that's
because of my personal connection to
Egypt I lived in Cairo for five years I
was involved in the Egyptian women's
movement and I did my PhD on the
Egyptian women's movement more
specifically I intend in this talk to
reflect on rage as a productive and
creative affect and force that is
gendered and gendering I will argue that
part of the tensions violence and
conflict is linked to the conversations
of new femininities and masculinities in
a context where as Denise Candiotti has
eloquently argued we cannot talk about a
routine manifestation of patriarchy
given the revolutionary challenges to
the States
hegemonic norms of masculinity and
femininity I would also like to share
with you my thoughts about the
positionality of rage and knowledge
production and the difficulties of being
truly intersectional in our rage
activism and scholarship now let me
start first by reading an excerpt of the
edited volume that was recently
published we Iraqis politics and
aesthetics in a time of war I tell you a
little bit about the book in a moment
but I now the image you see here is of
reefer Bilal he is an Iraqi multimedia
artist based at NYU and he engaged the
month-long performance art piece called
domestic tension where he was based in a
Chicago gallery with a paintball gun
aimed at him that people could shoot
over the internet I quote that day in
May 2007 the paintball shots were
particularly fast and furious and
psychologically debilitating the story
had been featured on deck comm so people
from all over the world were visiting
the site and fire and firing at me the
anonymity fostered brutal vicious leaks
and a phobic and racist comments and
naked aggression that day the non-stop
barrage of shots and highly disturbing
volley of often violent and humiliating
chatroom messages forced me to take
matters in my own hands I disconnected
the paintball gun without the viewers
knowledge and then in an oscar-worthy
performance acted like a terrified man
on the fire the room was so soaked in
yellow paint from the deluge of
paintballs that viewers could not tell
that the gun was not firing I acted like
I was badly hurt from being hit
paintball and exited the room the next
day I found a chat room was abuzz with
rumors that had been taken to the
hospital I felt a sense of triumph over
my trauma ters I was able to take
control of the image and use it to my
own ends now on various levels domestic
tension is a prime example of using art
to get people to examine their own
attitudes prejudices lives and behaviors
domestic tension is also a very powerful
example of the transformative power of
rage and creativity we fabulous
installation and performance not only
forced participants to confront their
own violence aggression and dehumanizing
behavior but it also empowered the
artists to take control to hold an
invisible mirror in mirror in front of
the thousands who happily participated
in violating him in very similar ways
that people who had been watching and
cheering the bombing of Baghdad and
other Iraqi cities in 1991 and 2003 now
as I mentioned earlier were fabulous
reflections on art is part of a wider
project I've been working on collecting
contributions by Iraqi artists writers
filmmakers poets photographers bloggers
and so on this illusioned by either
institutionalized politics or militant
resistance I have been increasingly
looking to cultural expressions and
cultural productions as arenas of
nonviolent resistance and of the
innovation inspiration vision and hope
now Iraq has become a case of worst
scenario come true with the toxic mix of
Western military and political
intervention a potent opportunistic
diaspora politics the emergence of a new
dictatorship as well as a reinvigoration
of an authoritarian political
culture at the same time you fought an
increasing significance of fiercely
conservative Islamist political groups
increasing gender-based violence and the
lack of basic infrastructure yet -
disillusionment with former party
politics and established political
channels extends to the revolutionary
processes we have seen unfolding in
other countries in the region more
specifically
I've been following events in Egypt and
at this point I should insert that I
find it absolutely necessary as some of
you already mentioned before to historic
size and also to be very specific when
talking about the gendered implications
of revolutionary and counter
revolutionary processes now while I do
believe in the power and need of
political mobilization through various
groups and organizations while I see
street politics as playing an important
role in terms of illusionary processes
but also wider political developments
I'm increasingly drawn to those spaces
outside of conventional political
practices and mobilization one of the
lessons I learned in Iraq and I see
currently unfolding in Egypt as well is
that established and even most new
political parties are modeled on
authoritarian and hierarchical
structures patriarchal norms and
relations and even if women might be
involved and they seem to lack in the
mechanisms and structures that allow for
creative and inspiring energies and
ideas to flourish now we are stuck with
political parties and I'm not suggesting
that we will get rid of them anytime
soon
but in terms of actual change and more
deep-seated transformations I would I'm
interested to look at political culture
rather than parties political cultures
about the way we do politics how we
relate to each other how we generate
ideas and make decisions
political culture refers to the
distinguishing beliefs
attitudes habits and behavior patterns
that characterize a political community
it is made up of cognitive affective and
evaluative orientations towards a
political system crucially it is a
creation of alternative spaces an
alternative means of doing politics that
carries the possibility of more profound
change and transformation and this is
where imagination writing music and art
are absolutely key it is in the sphere
of cultural productions whether in more
conventional art forms linked to theater
film music literature paintings
photography and so on or in new cultural
expressions linked to graffiti art
graffiti art hip-hop and blogging that
cultural spaces and productions can
challenge the very basis of how we think
of and do politics in any given context
now this is not to reduce art and
cultural productions to didactic tools
for politics and education I think that
functional approach to culture and art
is far too limiting simplistic and
linear but I'm thinking of the relation
between subcultures and alternative
cultural spaces and the emergence of
alternative oppositional cultures now
within the wider field of political
culture I've been now for some time
interested in the productive potential
of rage and we thought about rage
earlier on Corina I don't know oh that's
a shame now rage which is one of the
many concrete sentiments and
manifestations of an intensification of
feeling and it is intensification of
discomfort what cultural studies
scholars call an affective response that
might or my challenge or reproduce
existing social orders effect as a
feminist theorist Claire Hemmings tells
us broadly refers to states of be
rather than to their manifestations or
interpretations as emotions I should say
I'm not an expert in effect theory nor
have I been engaged in debates around
the effective term however I do find it
useful to think about emotional
investments political connectivity and
the possibility of change while
recognizing that effects are clearly
embedded within specific historical
social political and economic context
but cannot simply be reduced to them the
same time as we should allow in our
analysis for level of individuality and
idiosyncrasies and not reduced people to
categories I would like to stress that
effects and their associated emotions
such as rage take on collective lives
and dynamics become contagious and
intensifying crowds I'm a personal
history of rage has many sources and
both and is rooted both in individual
and collective experiences the pressure
to integrate and be more German than the
Germans as you see from my accent is
still there when growing up atrocities
committed against my family and friends
by the regime of Saddam Hussein the
invasion of Kuwait in 1990 the Gulf War
of 1991 a devastating sanctions regime
against Iraq for 13 years the invasion
of Iraq ten years ago occupation and its
link chaos lawlessness violence human
rights abuses but rage has also grown in
the context of wider policies linked
with the so-called war on terror racism
and more specifically Islamophobia but
that's not all a gender-based rage has
taken up a big chunk of my emotional and
political being it was in Cairo in the
late 80s and early 90s they entered the
world of feminist activism through
Egyptian friends who took me to meetings
and soon got me hooked feminist
scholarship provided me was the
vocabulary
and concepts to put words to phenomena
and processes that I was observing or
had experienced myself and experiences
that related to gender-based
discrimination zinni qualities overt and
more subtle forms of sexism misogyny as
well as homophobia now in the late 1990s
I met with a group of Iraqi and British
based women's rights activists and
started a group called act together
woman against sanctions on Iraq I mean
that was the initial name and then we
had to change it to act together woman
against sanctions and warned Iraq and
then later on we just called it act
together woman's action for Iraq now we
spent the first couple of years trying
to educate people in Britain and other
Western countries about the devastating
impact of economic sanctions on the
Iraqi population but particularly
focusing on the impact on women and
gender relations in terms of both the
humanitarian crisis but also more
restrictive gender norms aside from the
most obvious and devastating effects of
sanctions related to dramatically
increased child mortality rates
widespread malnutrition deteriorating
health care and general infrastructure
as well as unprecedented poverty and an
economic crisis women were particularly
hit by changing social climate State
discourse and policies as well as social
attitudes and gender ideology is shifted
dramatically during the sanctions period
in late 2001 we had to widen our focus
and started to campaign against the
British and American invasion of Iraq
from the beginning we made it clear that
we opposed both the repressive Baath
regime and American and British policies
on Iraq law demonstrations silent vigils
sit-ins and teach-ins
were part of our political repertoire
now in March 2003 we mounted an
exhibition called
our life and pieces
objects and stories from Iraqis in exile
at a gallery in central London our main
motivation at the time was to dispel the
idea that Iraq could be equated with
saddam hussein before 2003 hardly anyone
ever talked about iraq in terms of
ordinary human beings their fears hopes
and aspirations vision and we issued an
invitation to Iraqis in exile to
contribute objects which had a
particular meaning for them repositories
of personal familial and social memory
in history emblems talismans anything
they wanted to exhibit which had some
sort of symbolic value for them in terms
of the connection to Iraq now initially
women seemed more willing to contribute
objects and write their personal
accounts there men who often said they
hadn't brought anything with them we
also had to work hard to gain people's
trust the painful recent history of the
country had left Iraqis very wary once
this barrier was crossed however they
became intrigued and enthusiastic and up
to the opening of the exhibition people
were still contacted contacting us
wanting to bring in the objects and
stories in the end we had about 75
exhibits and so people not only gave an
object but they also wrote a story about
it you know why it is there chose this
now the opening of the exhibition in
March 2003 coincided with invasion of
Iraq the exhibition became a gathering
point for many Iraqis who feared for
their relatives and friends lives we
felt incredibly helpless sad and angry
but we also knew that we were making a
very small contribution to reminding
people in Britain that a military
intervention was affecting real people
on the ground as well as people living
in the Diaspora we also felt that we are
transforming our rage into something
creative and constructive
now my own personal trajectory of anger
frustration and political activism is
not unique in that one rage tends to
bleed into another the moment we
recognize that social injustice
inequalities human rights violations and
different forms of oppression are all
linked and interconnected engenders
theory of course we speak of
intersectionality the fact that gender
as a social category marking unequal
power relations and hierarchies
intersects with other markers of
difference and inequality such as
ethnicity race class religion sexuality
and so on now when we make these
connections it becomes impossible and
now I'm sort of bringing it back to
processes in the region then it becomes
impossible to not link revolutionary
struggles for the wider good of the
nation with those of marginalized groups
within and vice-versa
I personally could not have advocated
for women's rights in Iraq over the past
few years without also mobilizing
against neo-colonialist and imperialist
policies and processes as well as
against political authoritarianism of
Iraqi politicians unfortunately not
everyone who has been agitating against
US and UK intervention policies feels
that gender-based drives and violence
are part of their struggle through
political activism and engagement with
theory I developed my political
practices as a feminist in conjunction
with a struggle against racism
imperialism economic exploitation and
heteronormativity and the attempt to
find non hierarchical and nonviolent
ways of resisting these various forms of
intersecting hierarchies and
inequalities now this has been coined
transnational feminist politics and
praxis now a transnational feminist
politics is in reality in everyday life
however often very difficult and
requires painful decisions and turmoil
the tension between the need to address
women's rights and fight racism
Islamaphobia a particularly acute in the
context of the Middle East and the
so-called Muslim world and I will look
at this tension later on now coming back
to intersectionality as posed an
analytical tool but also political
practice most Iraqi women's rights
activists did not have to read any
gender theory to realize that their
struggle for increased gender equality
and social justice is closely linked
with a struggle against sectarianism
corruption and authoritarianism in Egypt
and intersectional approach was
initially rejected by revolutionary
activists most anyway including many
women activists themselves in the first
phase of the revolution many women's
rights activists and cops as well were
accused of sight lining the main issue
of neglecting the National duties and
betraying the nation and the revolution
I'm thinking here for example about you
know the first international Woman's Day
in Cairo 2011 when the small number of
women who came together to celebrate
International Women's Day were harassed
and accused of taking away attention
from the main issues some men who
attacked the female protesters claimed
that they were seeking to destroy Egypt
and undermined family values and the
sanctity of the family by telling women
to desert the husbands in this instance
it was obvious that the man surrounding
them were divided into those who felt
threatened by a woman's block making
their own demands and thereby
challenging the prevailing gender order
and those who stood in solidarity with
them recognizing that the woman's
demands were at the core of their own
vision and ideas of a new Egypt now
don't get me wrong I don't want anyone
to fall back into the trap of identity
politics in which communities or
gymnasts become essentialized and
reified represented by so-called
community leaders who might not actually
represent the diverse position
of any given group of people I'm not
advocating a politics based on
difference and identity alone but I
would argue that any revolutionary
struggle for the nation as a whole
similar to radical political
transformation or transition as we are
witnessing in Iraq today needs to
accommodate the struggle for its most
marginalized members with a based on
gender class religion or sexuality and I
would add that any hegemonic narrative
about the nation needs to be challenged
disrupted and creatively subverted as
part of evolutionary struggle for more
just and equal society unfortunately all
cross cultural and historical evidence
suggests that unless women explicitly
insist on their gender specific needs
rights and problems these will be
sidelined ignored and swept under the
carpet now a further lesson I've taken
away from Iraq and Syria kated again
maybe more so acutely in Egypt than in
Tunisia
is that democracy cannot be equated with
elections Saddam Hussein and the Baath
Party have been ousted yet the sharp
reality is forcing people to see that it
takes much more than a military invasion
and a new government to establish
democratic structures and to transform
an authoritarian political culture built
on patronage connections and corruption
there is a resilience of all patterns
and structures which were put in place
under the previous regime and which have
not been stabilized I'm sure this sounds
familiar to many of you working on Egypt
or Tunisia
although the means and contexts of our
of our stting other Ben Ali or Mubarak
were of course drastically very
different from the Iraqi context
besides elections a democracy needs
foundations such as freedom of
expression freedom of the media a strong
civil society an independent judiciary
checks and balances and the population
that is
not swayed by popular slogans but is
able to make educated choices and when I
say education here and not necessarily
speaking about school or university but
a political choice based on knowledge
and insight about political tendencies
programs policies of different parties
and candidates as well as underlying
worldviews ethics and visions personally
I think that democracy is an aspiration
rather than a reality anywhere in the
world including in so-called Western
democracies but it is the matter of
degree Iraq again is an example of a
country where elections were not
democratizing they will not democracy
democratizing at all but rather
institutionalized sectarianism as people
are voting along sectarian lines in a
situation of insecurity fear and lack of
services and just because elections are
held
it doesn't mean democracy is being
implemented worse in the absence of
viable democratic foundations elections
could become a dangerous exercise and
fuel political violence in such a case
winning elections is regarded as a
matter of death and life since the
winner takes it all and his powers
understand it's always his power
democracy is also not merely about
representing the majority but it is
about assuring the rights freedoms and
safety of those parties and followers
who lost or are in the minority
democracy is about assuring that those
who have different views from those who
have gained political control can still
be expressed without sanctions or
negative consequences except if they are
inciting to hatred and violence of
course there's a very thin line between
populism and democracy that is difficult
to balance at a conference I attended
last year on gender and the Arab Spring
a number of participants asked the
question is democracy bad for women now
I personally would not have put it this
way as I don't equate elections
democracy but I think that the question
deserves discussion and closer closer
attention historically women's rights
activists in the Middle East have been
challenged to not be co-opted by the
largely secular authoritarian states
modernizing gender policies and forms of
state feminism when dealing with a
dictatorship and the one-party system it
is very difficult for women's rights
activists to operate independently
outside given state structures yet in
the past authoritarian regimes have
implemented measures to increase gender
equality and social justice as long as
these were perceived to be harmless to
the regime and the status quo we have
seen this most conspicuously in Tunisia
and Iraq but also to some extent in
Egypt where some women's rights
activists collaborated with with Suzanne
Mubarak's National Union for women
however what also needs to be stressed
is that many women's rights activists in
the region within Iraq Egypt Palestine
Iran or Tunisia have historically been
intersectional in their approach to
gender peace based rights and have been
at the forefront of opposing political
authoritarianism economic exploitation
and imperialist policies Egyptian
women's rights activists for example
have been out on the streets to protest
against Israeli occupation the use US
invasion of Iraq and the exploitation of
factory workers yet despite this the
stigma and accusation of having worked
closely with the previous state was
heavily on women's rights activists and
needs to be understood as the point of
strategy to discredit them these
accusations are not new as in the past
it was about imitating the West and
working closely with the colonial powers
only now the implications and
consequences might be even more severe
ironically but again not surprisingly we
can see that women and gender issues are
taking center stage and the old true
gems attempts to hold on to power and
privilege and in the violent backlash
and counter revolutionary processes we
have been witnessing recently the
treatment of female protesters is taking
very different forms to that of their
male counterparts one of the early
analysis about the general implications
of the religion in Egypt has been
provided by the Egyptian historian and
activist Khalid fami he argued in 2012
that women's bodies had emerged as a
nexus for many of the principles and
objectives of the evolution Fatima put
it the following way I quote the
important role of women and the female
body in this revolution has manifested
itself on the many guises first came the
photographs in the nude
that Ali Ahmadi posted of herself on her
block in a bold gesture to challenge
existing taboos about the body and raise
fundamental questions about who owns and
rolls it then came the horrific video
footage of a young woman whose body was
stripped off of rail and closing she was
dragged and stomped in a naked offensive
list by army boots and this at the
doorstep of Parliament and cabinet
buildings then we watched the equally
horrifying footage of oz' Halal who
rushed to the defense of the woman in
the blue bra as the victim mentioned
above came to be famously known in the
english-language press only to find her
own body subjected to brutal beating
again by army soldiers and finally we
saw tens of thousands of women taking to
the streets in a mass rally of protest
against the Army's brutality and
systematic violation of the sanctity of
women's bodies these events show that
the female body is at the heart of this
great revolution in which women have
emerged as a driving and galvanizing
force now much has already been said
about this picture today so I don't
really want to go much into it I am
really sorry that Karina is not here
because I really appreciated her
analysis I guess what I wanted to do was
this picture was to sort of complicate
again sort of reactions and stressed
importance of context now my I guess one
of the things that is important to say
is that both it wasn't just you know
Islamist and sort of conservatives who
reacted to it but many sort of
progressive secular activists also
reacted to this and very much you know
they're very upset and you know
basically said this is not the right
moment to do this and this will create a
backlash I have to say that my own
initial sentiments and reactions very
much resonate what Kareena was saying
and my thought was really very well
expressed in Maya mcDuffie's excellent
article waiting for alia which was
published under Dalia on the 20th of
number November 2011 I'll just share the
concluding paragraph because I thought
it was really very well put my quote
earliest picture does not play by the
rules and this is why both liberals and
Islamists have condemned her condemned
her she is not waiting for the right
moment to bring our bodily rights and
sexual rights in post-mubarak Egypt
she's not playing nice with the
Patriarca power structures in Egypt
she's not waiting her turn her mouth is
not open and pouting her breasts are not
lodge her eyes are not hungry or afraid
she's not varying high heels her vagina
is uncovered she's not selling anything
and she's not trying to turn us on her
use of fishnet stockings appears to be a
commentary on the cliche of commodified
seduction her nudity is not about sex
but it aims to reinvigorate a
conversation about the politics of sex
and the uneven ways that is articulated
across the fields of gender capital and
control she is staring back at us daring
us to look at her to not turn away
daring us to have this debate and then I
was going to compare that to this
picture that you're all do a scene by
but I have a better quality picture so
when I saw this like Karina I mean I had
a very different reaction you know to
this then previous and you know we've
already discussed it and I actually very
much agree but I also would like to
share some pictures of famine who then a
great engaged in this topless jihad and
I think what I guess the point that I
wanted to make is that I find that
famine and the reaction to famine is
subsuming the acts of I mean in the sort
of critique and reaction I fear that the
X the original X acts of alia and Amina
which to my mind actually acts of
bravery and politically very different
from that but the reaction to the
colors the way people think about both
Ali and Amina and I what I'm asking us
to do is kind of be more careful in sort
of really looking more carefully at the
context and the meaning and sort of try
to disentangle that now similarly I'm
suggesting that we need to look at the
complexity is linked to the increase in
sexual harassment easy readings either
conclude that the epidemic of sexual
harassment in Egypt is an indication for
the fact that women's rights and spaces
for women are shrinking in the current
period others on the others point to the
orchestrated nature of harassment
now with the surge in intensity of
sexual harassment 100 sorry
while the search and intensity of sexual
harassment has increasingly gained
attention within media academia as well
as amongst women's and human rights
activists in Egypt and elsewhere I
personally would caution against the
tendency to reduce the wide range of
gender developments and phenomena linked
to current transformations to that of
harassment I mean I think there's much
more going on but I would also argue
that even a focus on harassment evokes a
mixed picture as the widespread
mobilization campaigning and advocacy
against harassment is unprecedented and
has allowed for previously sensitive
issue to be addressed publicly by
Egyptian women and I should stress by
Egyptian men this stands in drastic
contrast to the way harassment and even
wider forms of gender-based violence
were previously considered a taboo
subject I remember an incident during my
time of living in Cairo in the 1990s
when the new women's Research Center had
caused an uproar by having written a
research and policy paper on
gender-based violence at the group at
the time the group was harshly
criticized
even by some fellow feminists for trying
to impose Western issues and problems on
Egyptian society I know that debates
moved on quite a bit since the mid 90s
but still I think what we see right now
is a is a very quality in terms of
quality in terms of intensity quite a
big change in Egypt today harassment and
other forms of gender-based violence are
being talked about publicly and are at
the core of much mobilizing although
what I'm suggesting is that the focus is
on harassment in ways that is not always
useful
now sexual harassment and its
counterpart women's security and ability
to move safely in public spaces and
participate in political activities it's
not anymore perceived to be the
diversion from the wide evolutionary
struggle for greater equality and social
justice as it was initially the case
nowadays those parties groups and
individuals who see themselves as
holding on to the spirit of the volution
view the fight against harassment
essential to the wider demands and
visions for a new society it is
heartening to see the large number of
men of different generations in
solidarity although young men seem to be
particularly involved in anti harassment
campaigns such as harassment operation
anti-sexual harassment and diarrhea
bodyguard yet discourses about
harassment differ greatly ranging from
conservative protection discourses and
also propagated by president morsi and
conservative strands of the media and
political landscape to the prevailing
analysis of feminists and progressive
political forces focusing on the
authorities and the orchestrated nature
of the attacks here accusations ranged
from blaming the police the military
remnants of the former regime and the
Muslim Brotherhood now whatever the main
culprits are behind sexual harassment
quite a bit of what we are witnessing in
Egypt today
is clearly planned and instigated on the
25th of January this year the second
anniversary of Egypt's revolution at
least nineteen women were recorded to
have been sexually assaulted by gangs of
men these attacks were similar to
previous assaults during protests large
numbers of men moved jointly through
crowds working in a systematic and
orchestrated way way surrounding
individual women first in a u-shape than
fully encircling a woman in several
lines of men victims report feeling
confused by some men speaking about
protection by closing in on them and
attacking them in a most brutal manner
including stripping of their clothes and
raping them with objects and fingers the
focus on the patterns of attacks the
systematic and apparently orchestrated
nature and the question of instigators
scent in contrast to the sensationalist
tone of the UK's Channel 4 documentary
Egypt sex mobs and revolution aired in
December 2012 I don't know if any one of
you saw this the documentary addressed
the issue of harassment suggesting that
Egyptian men had turned into
uncontrolled sex crave mobs it made for
very uncomfortable watching especially
in my living room in London knowing
exactly how much of the British public
would interpret how you know knowing
exactly how the British public would
interpret this documentary it was
feeding right into stereotypes of
violent Muslim man oppressing their
women but and this is a sticky point for
me I have been increasingly wondering
whether there is not more going on than
simply state or police orchestrated
harassment and violence and I've also
been wondering whether a narrow focus on
harassment and gang attacks on women
might be short-sighted and problematic
on the long run to my mind there is a
continuum of harassment and gender-based
violence ranging from the orchestrated
sexual harassment of women during
protests to most spontaneous forms of
harassment
by groups of young men on the street and
the harassment girls and women have been
experienced for long time within schools
institutions at work as well as within
homes I think it is important to make
connections to domestic violence marital
rape FGM and honor-based crimes and
killings in addition to looking inward I
would suggest and I know that many
Egyptian feminists have already made
these links for many years that a more
long-term and holistic strategy against
harassment needs to include a campaign
for fairer economic redistribution and
crucially the campaign against the
systematic marginalization of women in
decision-making processes both within
governmental institution institutions as
well as many opposition and dissident
context furthermore and I realized that
this would be extremely controversial in
the Egyptian context I would argue that
capital punishment is a feminist issue
it is my family's friends in Iraq who
taught me the connections between a
society that normalizes violence whether
in terms of state control or resistance
to it and increase and the increase in
various forms of gender-based violence
now recognizing the danger of reducing
complex phenomena to a crisis and
masculinity or feeding international
security discourses and naturalizing
class-based sugery as palomar cautions
us against I still think that we need to
think more deeply and productively about
conversations of masculinities at this
particular historical juncture in Iraq
in Egypt and elsewhere in the region the
large presence of men in solidarity with
women is clearly a sign of changing
times and for men making connections
that did not do before on the other hand
elements of the military some political
parties the police and Secret Service's
deploy and make use of thuggish violent
masculinity store cert the authority and
intimidate women and men who resist and
there are many other processes and
phenomena phenomena going on that
require closer scrutiny such as a
celebrated militancy of ultras the
anarchic football fans who have been
fighting elements of the police and
security services during protest and I
have to say I personally felt quite
disturbed with the way that many of my
friends were kind of celebrating their
ultras as you know the kind of the
resistance of the state when I think in
terms of you know some of their
implications and especially in terms of
violence and you know the sort of gender
norms extremely problematic other
processes developments going on it's
increased in social conservatism with
its stress on Family Values and cohesion
the increased Islamization of public and
political discourses and the ongoing
extreme gap in access to resources
employment and political decision-making
now I recognize that masculinities and
femininities are always in crisis in
some ways and that meaning that they're
always contested polarized struggled
over and that this crisis
a lot to do with political economies
particularly in the context of Egypt and
my friend Nicola Pratt I think made is
very convincing argument and that in the
Egyptian contact sort of the impact of
structural adjustment and liberal
neoliberal economic policies have
created a situation where many Egyptian
men and women what they want is to be
real man again or real woman again and
it has a lot to do with the kind of
glorification of a past which never was
in a way you know where sort of woman
could stay at home and man could work
and it's because of economic conditions
that that was all muddled up and so a
lot of what we see in terms of tensions
links to this you know wanting to be
real man and women again but I think
that while you know crisis is always our
contestation is always part of you know
constructions and performances
performativity of masculinity and
femininity I think that the level and
intensity of conscious stations has
risen considerably as have the
possibilities of reimagining and pushing
boundaries now this might seem
contradictory and paradox given the
overall shift towards more conservative
gender norms and relations in some ways
and these are not only pushed by
Islamist political constituencies but
also by many ordinary people as well so
there is the kind of hardening of
boundaries and norms going on but at the
same time there's also there are
openings that profoundly challenge
hegemonic gender norms also I agree with
the nice continuity that we cannot
simply explain away what is happening as
patriarchy and misogyny when we look at
the honing in on women's dress codes a
mobility their sexuality their presence
during protests actually the honing in
on the fact that women are political
actors I would argue that the context is
radically different and as and in some
ways has been getting worse on for some
time
Candiotti has introduced the term
masculine
restoration to signal that when
patriarchy as usual does no longer feel
secure it requires higher level of
coercion and as she argues the
deployment of more varied ideological
State apparatuses to ensure its
reproduction and I would add that
they're often playing right into the
insecurities frustrations and anger of
men outside of the political elite who
feel challenged by women's aspirations
activism disobedience and desires now I
would like to conclude with the argument
that the messy and interconnected
sentiments of rage translate into
specific forms of activism mobilization
and academic interventions in ways that
are profoundly contextual and linked to
our respective position a letís
unfortunately much of what we do and say
is defensive and reactive often a
knee-jerk manner thereby falling into
the trap of dichotomous and polarized
statements and arguments that gloss over
complexities and nuances I'm thinking
for example about muna - how is article
why do the haters now there were lots of
things wrong in the article which appear
to blame Middle Eastern man as a group
for victimizing Middle Eastern women as
a group now I don't want to rehearse the
excellent critiques provided earlier
pointing to the historically rooted and
structural structural in justices and
forms of oppression such as colonialism
capitalism also a Terran ISM patriarchy
and neoliberalism affecting all women
and man in the region but despite my own
reservations of the packaging content
and tone of Howie's article I felt
uncomfortable with the lack of serious
attempts to look inward named and
confront those attitudes norms practices
and relations that cannot simply be
explained away by external and
structural patterns forces and processes
there is individual agency after all and
in the Khan
of Iraq for example not all forms of
gender-based violence can be reduced to
the occupation now over the past years I
have spent lots of time and energy as an
academic and as an activist to argue
against the culturalization
of what are political issues what
economic issues what are social issues
particularly with reference to
gender-based violence I mean that has
been you know big motivation force for
me for years I have felt compelled to
say and write it is not about their
culture but it is about political
economies it is about also a tear in
dictatorships and conservative
patriarchal interpretations and
practices
it is about foreign interventions and
invasions I know that the struggle for
women's rights intersects was a struggle
against other inequalities which in the
Middle East translates into the struck
into struggles against imperialism
sectarianism and so on now being based
in London my feminism certainly also
intersects with the struggle against
racism and Islamophobia throughout I
have tried to not become an apologetic
in terms of systemic human and women's
rights abuses in Iraq and elsewhere yet
I have to admit that I'm getting quite
frustrated or not quite I'm getting a
bit frustrated by my own constant
compulsion to have to fight Islamophobia
and racism in the first instance and in
that process sometimes end up glossing
over forms of gender-based violence the
political marginalization of women and
extremely socially conservative
attitudes towards women and gender
relations and I would argue and I know
that I might make myself not popular
here at by stating this they fear that
this compulsion is particularly
pronounced amongst my colleagues in the
US based in the US or some colleague
space in the US and there of course
obvious reasons for that I mean as I was
flying over here on Wednesday after the
horrible bombings in Boston I mean one
of the things that I was sort of very
worried about or was I was thinking is I
just hope it's not an Arab I hope it's
not a middle Easterner I hope it's not a
Muslim well I think we the good news is
that it's not a Middle East that they're
not Middle Easterners but there seem to
be Muslim I don't know how much of you
know how significant is about there are
two Chechnya brothers but so I mean I
know that this instance you know the
intensification of hate and racism what
is going to follow depending on what
we're going to find but the same time
I'm hearing and sharing the frustration
and anger of some of my family's friends
in Iraq and Lebanon and Egypt and
elsewhere
recently one Lebanese student and
activists told me Western scholars
constant obsession with refuting
Orientalism is orientalist in and of
itself and I would add it is also
ethnocentric although the same reaction
clearly exists within the Middle East
we're washing ones dirty laundry in
public is extremely problematic given
the way gender norms and relations have
been instrumentalized and the way also
homo nationalism has been involved has
been evoked to signify DIF democracy and
adherence to human rights this is not an
easy dilemma to get out of and I'm not
claiming to have answers and solutions
I'm painfully embroiled in this dilemma
myself so one example of the give it's
when I'm asked to give a talk about Iraq
one of the things that I should mention
and I do mention is that there has been
increased in honor-based killings but it
happened to me on several occasions that
I gave a talk and I thought it was quite
a nuanced talk for 45 minutes 50 minutes
and at some point I mentioned that there
has been increase in honor based
killings and I'm speaking about lots of
other things and then later on in the
discussion I find that the only thing
that my audience seemed to have picked
up on is that Iraqi fathers kill their
daughters I mean this is how what is
left so what do I do - I sort of censor
this out it's a difficult question
so I don't have answers but what I'm
suggesting is that we might try to find
ways and contacts to talk about this
dilemma in an
nuanced manner and to sort of address it
and I also think that I don't think that
all spaces are safe enough spaces to do
that I think that you need to to feel
it's the right context and I felt that
keynote for Jim use was the right space
to raise these issues thank you yeah I
can I think I'm I can manage so actually
what I'd like to do if you don't mind if
there are some questions and comments
that I gather a few and then so I can
sit for a moment
and I related to social and economic
class and possible possibly sexual
frustration related to the burden of
Darwinism baritone even think that you
know that people are waiting three years
to save up enough money to get an
apartment so that they can you know
resent themselves as a you know room for
a supergroup or you know right to what
effect those factors play in
thank you appreciate it and I appreciate
you sharing vulnerable and I'm really
glad that this is a very safe space
my question on top of that question how
much of it should we how much of this
sexual violence should be contributed to
economic factors versus problems of
masculinity and patriarchy as a young
Egyptian woman myself I've struggled
with this I understand there are
socio-economic frustrations sexual
frustrations but at the same time it
doesn't make it okay to and to sexually
violate them so this struggle in this
tension that we talk about I'm
interested to see what your responses
okay so I mean it's a two excellent
questions that are linked so I will
answer them together I am I guess I
wouldn't make that same distinction
because I do think that I mean the
distinctions in terms of on the one side
economic factors and then on the other
side sort of crisis of problems of
masculinity and patriarchy I think they
are actually really linked to each other
I mean I do think that so what what does
it mean to be a man is so much linked up
to being the economic provider being the
breadwinner you know being able to yeah
well to protect so I think that economic
factors are crucial very important and I
think that
at the same time I don't think that we
should be determinist in terms of
economic factors there's so many things
going on so Susan you speak about mob
violence and I mean this is a quite
problematic term but I think that what
it points to is that some of the
violence that we see is actually it's
there's not only sexual violence against
women although this has been the most
visible but there are other forms of you
know collective violence going on so for
instance I don't know exactly when it
happened but a few months ago you know
two young men who were caught caught
stealing something ended up being
lynched by a group and killed basically
and and I I do think there are
connections there so okay so one context
is the context of chaos and lawlessness
and so that's where I've sort of again
sort of think about Iraq you know what
happened after the invasion where you
have to kind of have a you don't have a
state anymore a functioning state you
have a kind of survival of the fittest
situation you have the looting going on
so that's I think that's one reason we
see violence any kind of violence now
the question that I'm interested in and
I I have to think more about it why is
it that in Iraq there was not more I
mean there was terrible violence but
there was not pronounced or mainly sort
of gender-based sexual violence there is
lots of domestic violence going on and
yes of course women have been harassed
and have been raped but it's very
different than in Egypt so what is it
about Egypt that it becomes such an
important model and I think that you
know Deniz Kenyatta's argument is really
important here it's because of course
women are much more involved in politics
in Egypt than in Iraq you know in Iraq
women have been although historically
women were very much sort of part of
Education and labor force but
politically they haven't really paid an
important role
but in Egypt I mean women are there
there are in trade unions and you know
in political parties there are in all
professions they have been part of the
protest and so what is at stake in terms
of this mask in this restoration there's
much more and how better to try to tell
a woman that your place is not here on
the street than at home is then through
sexual harassment and so I think what
what I'm trying to say and I think don't
know if you sort of notice the kind of
paralia said I don't think we should
explain away the different forms of
harassment in one way so similar in the
way that I'm asking us or that I'm sort
of challenging us to look at alia matys
you know a picture of herself in the
nude is very different from the pictures
later on with famine I want to think
that yes there is orchestrated sexual
harassment going on and you know all my
friends are focusing on that and they're
good reasons to focus on that but that
is not the full picture and you know
people who have worked in the
countryside who worked in school we tell
will tell you that there has been
rampant harassment in many places and
that is not stayed orchestrated yes
clearly there is an element of sexual
frustration but again you know other
parts of the world that there's that as
well you cannot explain it away with it
yes I mean education well I mean but
education in maybe in the sense that I
think what is happening a lot is that
there is a kind of mismatch between
especially with the increase actually in
internet and media and the sort of
awareness of sort of images of women I
think there is that as well and I mean I
I know that there's also a little bit of
that happening in the Iraqi Kurdistan
that with access to Internet and
pornography and mobile phone technology
and satellite television gender-based
violence actually increased I think
there's this so I don't think it's one
I always get very suspicious when I hear
kind of monel causal explanations I
think it is very complex but what I like
to explore more deeply is I think that
is yeah okay thank you for the really
thought-provoking excellent and also
very personal presentation so you know
you said this if you look at other
examples of earlier revolutions in the
Middle Eastern region where women's
issues and agendas were sort of not on
the table and they were expected to soar
to subsume their interests under the you
know cloak of a minor revolution it
hasn't gone well afterward and in
reading this this morning I just sorted
is that what you're suggesting in Iraq
that basically things really haven't
gone well for women there because their
issues externally they were put on the
table you know that was a point of one
of your books what kind of liberation
the u.s. used women in Iraq is sort of
the reason to go and would be liberators
but it wasn't an internal kind of
struggle and it didn't
very well in Iraq if maybe no that's a
simplistic overview but could you say a
little bit more about that and so in
Egypt since you use this as the main
example today because women activists
are really more active and have been out
there and there's a long history of
feminism in Egypt you know not that
you're you know I'm asking to
prognosticate but do you think there
could be an eventually different outcome
in these revolutionary moments in the
Middle East where women have really been
out there mobilized along with men might
in the long term there'd be better you
know a better future for greater gender
equality though it's going through a
very difficult period you know I would I
would say so what do you think I guess
from the historic examples to the
potential future could there be a better
future
my name is 9 and the sauce brand I first
of all I think I what I want to say to
you personally is that I'm I'm honored
to have passed in one of your classes
every time I need something for you and
then and listen to you again I discover
new things and I'm I'm really glad that
there is someone actually there I guess
more but I that I'm in close in contact
on an exposure diet with someone who is
suppose an academic and an activist and
it's extremely it has been a struggle to
make the links between activism and
research but so I wanted to ask a
question on the the possibility
possibilities of collaboration between
the two in in Lebanon there is an
ongoing debate and activism circles
today it feels like activists are so
consumed with the legal issues that they
are so good to lose either passing the
law or like polishing code from a penal
code or something so but and then
there's another trend saying that's well
laws are not everything and it doesn't
if you have law it doesn't mean that say
the Resta violence can be solved or has
changed or anything so I was just
wondering if there were any suggestions
on on areas of intersection with the to
collaborate activists and researchers
what else can we do and I'm bringing up
the domestic violence example because
it's where the most and the link between
the two has been most obvious there has
been researched significant research
work on documenting the mastic violence
cases honor killings and and related
issues and the necessity of the law and
how you know why it's it's important for
us to advocate for it
so is there other are there I'm sure
there are but what do you think of other
so like maybe have another round
afterwards yes the website um
I mean when you think about I mean this
is I guess was I mean so yeah Johnny I
mean women and gender studies how did it
emerge I mean it didn't just emerge in a
sort of political vacuum it emerged as
part of the or as the result or in
connection no in conjunction with the
women's movement so I never actually
thought about women and gender studies
as something sort of separate from
activism clearly it has the way it's
been institutionalized and they way of
course also academia has been going
there are tensions and there are
separations but I I strongly feel that
they're closely connected and that's why
when currently I'm actually involved in
Iraq in trying to facilitate the
introduction of Women and Gender Studies
I do that by bringing Iraqi women's
rights activists and Iraq academics
together on the table but also by sort
of linking them up with regional
academics and activists so in terms of
the methodological and practical tools
well okay so one methodological tool is
language as I already mentioned that yes
I mean I think there is as an academic I
have to like everyone else in Britain we
have something called the research
assessment exercise or framework and so
we have to publish in certain journals
we have to show our academic credibility
and so I have to do that and that
sometimes means that maybe you know I
have to sort of write in a more in a way
that might be sort of more jargony or
theoretical but generally I'm on the
conviction and I'm I what generally I
think that you can actually express
complex ideas in an accessible manner
I also think that what I've been trying
to do is to reach out to non-academic
audiences so there was a time at the
height of the violence in Iraq where I
mean there was one year I came to the
states I think eight times in 2006-2007
and every time I was invited to give an
academic talk I insisted on also giving
a talk in a communities and the center
in a bookshop in a woman's organization
I thought it was very important to not
just take and I think that's
particularly in this country which I
think there is a real a big gap between
sort of until you know intellectuals
academics and then the wider public I
mean I feel that more strongly when I'm
here than in Britain or in Germany and
so I feel it's very important for me to
find ways to sort of reach out but then
I guess act together was also a concrete
practical tool and method to combine
this I mean I used the knowledge and the
theoretical and conceptual tools I had
in my activism and also when I would
give talks I mean I as you might have
gathered from my talks and you might
also know from my writings
I abhor dichotomies and the sort of
black and white depiction of the world
as an activist and as an academic and I
feel you know one feeds the other and
strengthens the other I mean I I can't
I mean I've some of the worst moments I
had politically was being in a room in
2005 this was an Istanbul the world
Tribune of Iraq which was sort of a
series of tribunals it was sort of
anti-war activists from all over the
world and you know for I was on the
panel with Samir Amin and I was so proud
to be on a panel with Samir I mean and
then for three days I was hearing people
either starting or ending their talks
was we have to support the armed
resistance in Iraq at that time almost
on a daily basis there were Iraqis being
killed in bombings and marketplaces or
and I just thought I can't do that and
when it was my time she gets a talk it
was to talk about the impact of the
occupation on women in Iraq I start up
by saying I cannot do this here and I
think it's really what are you talking
about which kind of resistance are you
talking about
and had 300 people in the room hating me
Samir I mean jumped up and he said this
is not the time to be divisive we have
to unite against the US imperialism and
it was horrible but you know it was
horrible at the time but it really
retrospectively actually made me much
stronger and it was you know my I
couldn't make tools I think that allowed
me then to react but again it sort of
fed into activism and so act together
which is has been really wonderful I
mean there are women who are filmmakers
there you women who are housewives a
really range of women and sometimes I
mean I was every week you know on the
street holding placards I mean we're
doing this but the same time we also
organized exhibitions or day talks and
conferences media I've done lots of
media stuff I mean the first time I was
a PhD student I was asked by BBC for
women's hour which is the sort of famous
program I was asked to give a talk about
women and the sanctions in Iraq and then
a week before the program they know a
day before the program they called me
and said well we want to speak about
children as well can you talk about
children I don't know anything about I
didn't know anything about children at
the time so I called all my Iraqi
friends you know how did your children
experience sanctions how did they
experience the invasion I came to the
program it was life there was another
woman there of psychologists today's
program we're speaking about British
children's fears of Saddam Hussein I
mean speaking of rage I mean you know
you could see my heart going like this
but you know it was life so you know
after they sort of discussed you know
how poor British children couldn't sleep
because they were worried that Saddam
Hussein made sort of send some missile
on British playgrounds and he had
actually people calling in and asking
what can I do my child cannot sleep at
night well you know you have to explain
and but then it was my turn to speak and
so then I managed to actually turn it
around and sort of say you know what
about Iraq it chill and this that you
know they have real issues going on and
afterwards actually people calling in
focused on Iraqi children so while I
always found it or I often find it
traumatising media because it can be
very harsh I mean I sometimes find
myself sort of between three man you
know trying to get a word in but I think
it's important at the same time I don't
want to do too much of it because I
think there's a soul of whole
construction of expert and I don't
really want to get too much involved in
that but also I mean I think that for
instance the book Iraqi women untold
stories from 1948 to the present I've
wrote it having a wider readership in
mind and I think it has and I was very
happy that it has been serialized in
Iraq so people have been reading it in
the newspaper so I thought so I mean
okay let me just go sit off a little bit
more in two days before I move to
tomorrow so I think it is very important
for Lebanese feminist scholars to work
together with Lebanese activists and yes
I think there is the problem in focusing
only on loss I mean I think that sort of
the classic liberal rights feminism it
is important but we know not only that I
mean has happened in Iraqi Kurdistan yes
there is now a law that criminalizes
honor based killings but does anyone
care is it implemented does anyone
follow it do women know about it so I
mean it's you know in there has to be
there has to be consciousness-raising
they have to be you have to think about
who has access to law with access to
lawyers there's certainly a sort of
economic aspect to it as well and yes I
think it is very important to make the
connections and I you know very much
hope that
there are links by mean there's some
amazing you know scholars activists and
I very much hope that they sit together
as I think a really good example in the
region is actually many but one is the
birds ate woman Study Center which is
you have amazing scholars that are
internationally recognized but are very
much rooted in local women's feminist
activism and in Egypt as well I mean who
did solder and the woman in memory forum
or think there are lots of examples yes
I mean I'm not suggesting that if women
raised their voices and make their
claims from the beginning that it
guarantees that it that they get there
but what I'm suggesting is that this
tendency to always think of the bigger
issue first whether it's liberating the
nation liberating the poor oppressed
workers you know getting rid of dictator
and then afterwards we look we know
historically and cross-culturally that
doesn't work and that was why I was
actually very very upset and frustrated
initially when even some of my feminist
friends said well but we are not here as
feminists we are here as Egyptian I
think that changed drastically of course
but that was sort of the first impulse
and I was sort of trying to understand
why that was and I think it has a lot
had a lot to do with the fact that there
was a sort of element of inclusive it
inclusivity and actually you know lots
of people rather you know based on
religion or gender there was the kind of
collective sentiment in the first sort
of 18 days but when you look at Iraq it
was actually not that women didn't raise
the issues its despite I mean there was
this rhetoric of women's liberation but
very early on there were lots of
humans rights activists who saw through
this and actually who noticed that
despite this rhetoric of women's
liberation no one was going to hand them
woman's right from the platter and they
had to fight for it so you know I always
give this example of the woman's quota
because often when I come to the states
and people tell me but Iraqi woman got
the quota I say yeah but they got a
despite us objection you know it was in
spring of 2004 a group of Iraqi women's
rights activists went to see them
ambassador Paul Bremer and they said we
Araki women are actually the majority of
the Iraqi population and we want to have
a part in the new Iraq you want to have
40% representation in all you know
government decision-making institutions
and government bodies and Paul Bremer
looked at them and he said we don't
occur just you know that story so I
don't think there it was the issue that
women did not try to put the issue I
think they sure was that it was the
first thing that dropped off everyone's
agenda when we had the shift from human
security to national security you know
in 2005 and 2006 when sectarian violence
and insurgent violence increased human
rights women's rights who cared about
this arming the arming of militias and
we know from the Wyatt excellent
feminist scholarship international
relation scholarship that there is a
close relationship between the increased
militarization in the society and the
increases in gender-based rights and
inequalities now but as for your
question whether I do think that in
Egypt because women have been more
active whether there might be a
different outcome well so my point is
that the outcomes are very mixed I think
that's okay I can't really project
what's going to happen in 20 years but
what I see now when people say oh yes
you know poor women in Egypt say but it
is a very mixed picture you know the
very fact that you now have women
mobilizing around issues such as terror
and the very effect that there are men
mobilizing with them it's amazing
you know and when I compare that to Iraq
that would not happen could not happen
there so but what I see emerging in
Egypt and I think maybe we've also seen
it in Lebanon is this really very
polarized society so you have on one
level actually you know men and women
and they tend to be younger but not all
sometimes older who really really
challenging prevailing gender norms and
also you know often challenging although
they cannot do it outwardly
heteronormativity there is that but then
at the same time the sort of more
conservative and even some extremist
parts are I think gaining in strength
and intensity and so what I'm seeing is
really a very mixed picture and very
polarized society now where that is
going to go we don't know I mean what
I'd like to think given the pluralism
given the level of education given the
long history of creativity and cultural
expression is that yes you can sort of
push through a constitution that is
quite horrible but you cannot really
silence and totally stop these very
creative forms of resistance I mean I
think that's where I'm putting my hopes
and aspirations are you know there's
still this amazing theater and concert
and thirds and films and I think so yes
I I think I think we see both
yes I mention this because actually
something similar was done here in
Oregon I don't know favor with and also
in memories what do you feel is what
they take away with them wondering we
help to connect and my comment is you
mentioned about in Iraq particular types
of violence did not happen whereas in in
Egypt they did to the level I mean of
course as arrest violence yeah well I
just briefly wanted to comment that in
my experience and my knowledge
it has did not happen to the extent
because somehow despite all the anxiety
and everything that took place the
communities came together often people
even in the big cities people knew each
other and they would know who someone
chose doctor was me who so onto a sister
but that doesn't mean it didn't happen
I'm sure you know plenty of fun I think
that may be one reason - hi I am Katie
Bell from the ethical Society
Foundations and I just wanted to go back
to what you were saying a little bit
about Iraq um for my son it just sounds
like things are sort of stagnant though
so what might be a game changer for
women's rights issues in that country
what could women at the grassroots level
and NGOs and government across society
what what might they be able to do or
want to do or be likely to do in the
coming years that could change the
situation for them what might mobilize
manner or push sort of past the blockade
that they're facing
hi I'm Chloe I think I already said two
before and my question is actually about
lessons learned from Iraq and and what
happened there in terms of women's
rights under occupation and in the midst
of a humanitarian crisis and wondering
if you have any thoughts or ideas about
applying it to the context of what's
happening in Syria right now whether
there's anything to clean any captions
to make with women's rights activists in
that country particularly when dealing
with the influx of refugees to other
other states in the region hi I'm Sarah
where I come from my first University
thank you Nadia that was always a
pleasure to hear me speak I did more
about theoretical question I was really
interested in your when you when you
said the cognitive affective and
evaluative aspects of political culture
and the role of cultural productions in
that area and I was really quite struck
with the people exhibit in particular
and by a fact I suppose in relationship
could you elaborate a little bit more on
this so I understand a little bit more
as specifically related to conceptions
of masculinities and femininities I
- restoration okay I think that's plenty
okay so first question was okay so we
organized this exhibition and I
understand that there were similar
exhibitions in in the US what do I think
people took away from this yeah that
yeah I think that's a really good
question
I think in some ways most of the people
who came to the exhibition originally
who were people who already
I mean who did not have to be convinced
that Iraq was not just Saddam Hussein I
mean it was the kind of self selective
audience but because of the timing which
was of course not planned and it was
horrible but because it coincided with
the invasion I mean sort of day after or
two days after the opening so all kinds
of people actually came and the
exhibition was covered by CNN but there
were lots of media I mean I didn't do
kind of you know study into people's
sort of long-term reception but I I do
think and I know for myself that just
sort of hearing on the media sort of
numbers or you know sort of abstract
ideas about people it doesn't really
resonate so much so I want to believe
but I have no evidence I cannot I want
to believe that at least for some people
it just helped to humanize Iraqis but I
mean I think one of the problems that I
also face is okay so I want to reach
wider audience whether with an
exhibition or a talk who are the people
who are coming who are the people to
come to see an exhibition in Iraq is for
the people who come to here someone was
my name speak about Iraqi women
I mean I really think that maybe only
twice or three times in my career so far
I've generally had to face audiences
that were totally sort of different
politically so usually it's more like
minor points you know I mean I I'm
always hoping for it I once had this
talk in Colorado Springs and actually
well I was invited to Colorado College
and that was went very well and I mean
no surprises there but then because I
insisted on having something the
community little did I know what the
community so I was giving a talk at the
world affairs council and so these were
all either
military people or retired military
people or there were also lots of sort
of quite rich business people and I was
giving a talk about gender-based
violence in Iraq and yes it was
interesting you know but I'm glad you
know I think it's important so I you
know I want to believe that it makes a
difference I mean I would be sitting in
my room depressed if I don't believe
that it makes a difference and I think
you know we have to do and I think I do
think that it is good to use different
media and yes I'm sort of most with the
written word and the spoken word but I
think that art culture exhibitions are
very important film actually very
important means as well Katie yes so
what I was described it wasn't quite
stagnant situation what could be a
game-changer in Iraq actually I don't
think it stagnant
I think it's deteriorating I think that
several things are happening one is that
despite I mean there was all these sort
of you know human rights women's
liberation but there were other issues
demilitarized Iraq today Iraq is one of
the most militarized societies in the
region okay it is scary the amount of
weapons the amount of well I mean both
in terms of sort of small smaller
handguns and sort of big weapons getting
rid of also a terrorism as we speak we
have the emergence of a new dictatorship
and I think it's already there what is
different is that it's not uncontested I
mean there are kind of many dictators
contesting the main dictator but I
showed you the picture of newer Maliki
when he first came became president in
2006 no one gave him much I mean much
weight and people thought he is very
weak you know it's not going to but he
actually outmaneuvered political
opposition and what we see emerge is a
new dictatorship authoritarian Islamist
Chia okay so it's also very sectarian
and as the reaction to that you have
also a kind of Sunni resistance that
unfortunately as we those of you who
follow news you know the day there was a
bomb in Boston there was another bomb in
Baghdad over 30 people killed and that
is actually we hear only you know I
think s if it's sort of above 20 we hear
it but I know from friends and
colleagues that it's almost a daily
occurrence again so it's actually
getting worse and in that context it is
increasingly difficult for women's
rights activists and for women generally
it's different in the north in the
Kurdish area where the KRG the Kurdish
regional government is very much using
women and gender relations to demarcate
difference with the central government
and so women's rights activists have a
little bit more leverage there and they
have been able to push through certain
laws but at the same time you know
implementation is another issue
now what would help
women in Iraq which would help women's
rights activists in Iraq okay so some
things that really really I find really
upsetting aside from the overall context
but sort of more specific issues for
example initially there was all this
money you know pushed towards Iraq in
often in ways that were not very thought
through so building women's centers I
mean you know women's centers and then a
few photo opportunities with Condoleezza
Rice and in front of the Women's Center
no one is using these women's centers or
if they're using it but not women's
rights activists or you had these
democracy training workshops and my
friends call it the five-star tourism a
training tourism but now money has
stopped okay because Iraq is now
officially a middle-income country okay
so actually any sort of meaningful
projects are not being funded anymore
it's very difficult I mean yes you and
women are funding several project but
it's not so much only about money it's
also about solidarity and exchanging of
knowledge and expertise for instance to
my mind what would be hugely beneficial
would be for Iraqi women's rights
activists to meet up not with the
American gender advisor or the British
or the German but with their colleagues
in Egypt or Lebanon or Palestine or
turkey or Iran for that matter I think
or you know even with you know feminists
in South Africa or in Bosnia and I think
these connections would really make a
difference in terms of I I think what is
very difficult for Iraqi women's rights
activists even more so than for those in
Egypt is this whole accusation of
imitating the West and at the same time
having this training in gender and
democracy that is not really taking
context and historical specificity and
historical trajectories and
account that's one the other thing I
mean all the women's rights activists
that I know know not all but many of
them are very much at the forefront of
challenging the regime right now so they
know that what would help women greatly
if would be greater pluralism more
transparency rule of law all this is
actually not happening you have a
corrupt
I mean corruption is so rampant right
now in Iraq political violence is so
rampant so I think that also yes some
international pressure to actually hold
the government to account in terms of
rule of law in terms of transparency
might be helpful as well
I think it's other than that I think
sort of from the outside it's very
difficult I mean I do think that many
Iraqis to appreciate the kind of you
know connecting whether it's sort of
academics being able to spend some time
outside or students being able to go
outside or activists meeting up I think
that is really useful but we can't
really sort of here at Yale kind of come
up with the plan you know that has to
sort of come from from inside but at the
same time I'm also very critical of this
attitude well you know that's it's you
know we're out there in terms of the
military just that forget about Iraq
anyway we have now have to think about
well I have to think about North Korea
and we have to think about Afghanistan
and Iran and so I think that I don't
think of like a game changer per se but
I think there are several things that
can be done politically in terms of
Education in terms of solidarity and
facilitating encounters with regional
academics and activists Chloe
yes okay so lessons learned from Iraq I
mean on a very basic level everything
that we learned from Iraq means that
it's going to be very messy in Syria
very very messy now in terms of the you
know gendered implications I mean one of
the things that has happened with
internally the placed women woman
refugees and geno in Iraq you have a
situation where in some parts of Iraq
there were 70% female-headed households
and I suspect they're sort of similar
things happening in Syria as more men
are being killed and have been killed
historically as well you know by the
regime and what happens then this very
vulnerable female-headed households and
in the Iraqi context what we see and
actually it was happening lot in Syria
was the increase in prostitution
trafficking and I think that's I suspect
that we might also see you know
trafficking actually taking root in
Syria yes I mean but also I think that
in terms of the sectarian violence I
think that is is unfortunately going to
be part of the future of Syria and
sectarian violence is always linked with
using women's bodies women's dress code
women's mobility to demarcate boundaries
between us versus them
so I also suspect that there will be an
increase in gender-based violence and in
kind of restrictions women and gender
relations Sarah well I mean so the
niskin deity who is I think most I mean
she is of course I think all of her
articles have kind of have become sort
of paradigm-shifting and I probably know
there's no woman and general bill in its
class that doesn't have a few of her
articles and of course one of the things
that she's
known for its a whole idea of Patriarca
bargain and and what is interesting is
that she's kind of moving away from that
herself and and so for her this whole
idea of masculine is restoration denotes
situation where because of the fact that
you know women are very much present in
the public sphere because women are very
much active in political participation
you know we just cannot speak of a kind
of routine patriarchy at work but
there's something much stronger much
more violent much more intense at play
and I guess when I was speaking about
political culture I mean that's
something that I'm sort of you know
starting to think about and I want to
sort of theorize more but what is
important for me is having looked at
Iran's political transformation and also
looking at what's happening in Egypt is
clearly you know although I have lots of
friends who are very invested in
specific political parties opposition
parties and they're you know have been
working underground and in both in Iraq
and also in Egypt what really what I
find so disappointing is the
relationship to politics and decision
making is very similar which explains
that a Marxist can easily become an
Islamist it's the kind of it's the
relationship to an ideology so you can
you have the ideology and you kind of
have a you take it all as a whole
holistic thing and you don't have a sort
of critical engagement with it and so he
can do that with which happens actually
and not only that but there's also very
inbuilt hierarchical or soit Arianism
and so what I'm trying to think is you
know what are
looking and this is again very much the
anthropologist in me not there not being
so much interested in the content so are
these liberal social democrats or these
communists or these Islamists but what
is the relationship to political
decision-making and not only you know in
terms of the the cognitive but also the
affective one in terms of you know
sentiments what kind of emotions are
being evoked and to which kind of
emotions to people react politically and
yes it is very much gendered in the
context as you described you know the
whole and whether it's you know with
respect to the construction of the
nation memory we cannot think about it
outside of gender terms and it's
gendering in it as well so it's both
gendered but it's also actively
gendering context society social reality
perception self